what Chuck reject nation
Greg Alba here John Humphrey here Rene
like how Rene always does he's like half
committed bits but I like doing
committed lis somewhat yeah you do fit
and we're very intimidated top five
unknown 5 most mysterious sightings
captured on baby monitors oh I didn't
see the baby monitor part that's creepy
another reason I'm never having kids you
gotta teach someone they're young to be
self-reliant we got this all right so
let's after we watch this then we'll
talk about the ones that stand out those
to us on here baby monitors are
typically purchased by parents to a
child just to keep tabs on them while
they're away
however some pretty horrifying moments
have been accidentally captured on them
over the years
number five in this first clip the
uploader states that she had been
hearing strange noises coming from her
baby some commenters claimed that the
noise could be alien in origin seemed to
think clearly her the words a simple
baby and now it's super creepy and has
yet to be explained
shut the baby if it's in the help so
your baby walk the room is strange
object baby monitors the user states
this is what my wife caught on the baby
water my mom came home to check it out
where this happened and I wish they
would have gotten that curtains on video
as well she weaved the sheets up and
down and the lights moved around her
hands but never touched her they made
sure that there was no reflection of
anything and we can't figure out why the
lights hover and move when there was
nothing in the room that would move or
make a reflection everything was clean
and clear of dust - I've researched this
and haven't seen any lights like it
online take a look and let us know what
you think it may be your baby is your
baby under it I think it's just blankets
what is I don't either girl
this is Satan gizumon
looks kind of cute actually looks like a
little animal you have it's adorable
save it it's a ghost cat say something
to it it was cat it's got weird eyes
[Music]
I'm not in there she you see it like on
the camera first go in the room let's
see the baby is there yeah but you turn
on the light this is still in the
moderate no it's it's off the light turn
off the light
is it gone well it's also light
stop it oh no oh this next clip is taken
a segment of Inside Edition as you'll
see the moment of why are you have the
children's playroom shortly thereafter
you can see the kids nanny on a separate
camera rushing through the home to go
check on the children what whoa what the
hell just happened what the house has
happened like the wall first in okay
gentlemen is there room just fine
apparently this explosion took place in
the exact spot to the children spend
most of their time and it's a miracle
that they weren't in the room at the
time of the explosion take a look at the
after room where she was sleeping so
baby Lily would have been very good what
a bit dead baby whoa this next video is
the stuff of nightmares
we go I hear the stream is returning to
the babies water I've tried changing
frequencies and it's still the safe
what usually happens is like even music
start to play then when it stops he
wakes up I've gone through his room
looking for the source but the three are
so toys the place sounds have the
batteries taken out I can't think of any
other interference that might make this
creepy music now listen
[Music]
whoa ooh my eyes got teary-eyed man I
got nipple chills now man
how's intense I'm freaked out ain't no
music turn it back on lawyer in there
yeah she's life's fried chicken ears oh
okay
dude that's it this final video went
viral on Facebook in 2016
and she was what the hunter claims is a
ghost on a baby water she states final
state I won't be sleeping very well
tonight
I didn't believe in ghosts and about
five minutes ago this is a video taken
for my baby monitor of a ruby in bed
Ruby is in the front top left corner of
the table in her room with the door shut
nobody else is in there or so I thought
you can make up your own mind but I'm
one freaked out mother right now
the following video shows a strange
translucent figure moving around the
child's cot the son even claiming that
it looks like the ghost of another baby
I'm not sure have a look thank you Oh am
I missing something
Oh oh wow that's really moving come back
to the further where'd it go if it comes
with a camera I actually eat the camera
oh my gosh what is that why is it
haunting a baby why isn't she saying
anything ghosts always want babies looks
so real oh that's so weird
wow I can see it it does look like a
baby
Thanks
at least I don't have children this
could be my life well none of this will
ever happen to you if you don't have a
baby monitor that's true
but could you imagine like I'm I'm such
by anxiety like if I have a baby and I
got a baby monitor I would not look away
from our just constant stare and wait
for it goes oh so clear that's a baby
that's a dead baby this is Deb Davis
dead walking baby why is it pacing back
and forth like sit down
cuz that baby as long as business to
think of humble baby has a long-ass
video this one baby is walking around
why isn't she saying anything why can't
she be like oh there's a ghost baby oh
look at the ghost bit like something
she's just so you really calm or muted
the video yeah ghost baby she needs to
check with the internet first the
internet knows weird we think it could
be if it's not a ghost
you know like Jesus sensor being from
something else
dickey betts so to watch this video be
sure to click that like button
soon I will like the video just for Utah
five unknowns since you let us do
reactions to your videos okay okay well
you know what these weren't as
terrifying as I expected them to be
which is better for my personal life
yeah not as great for a video editor for
my personal life I'm not gonna have
nightmares yeah exact killing my mother
but I've heard the theory about you know
baby monitor walkie talkies too but
specifically baby monitor is like
talking to aliens and stuff cuz
walkie-talkies aren't as creepy no
they're not but a baby monitor yeah I
think aliens will want babies - mm-hmm
maybe they're you know want to find out
what happens when we're just starting
out you know I wish I was abducted by an
alien no no no you don't you don't tell
me how I feel by the way just like a
question is like today's are today's
reactions like parent theme I thought
one of the creepier ones was the second
one with they're like hanging yeah like
thing appearing that disappears when you
turn the lights on no the music one you
guys the music one is so only music wow
that's so creepy nothing I hate more
than like you know any scary movies when
they have kids singing yeah that's like
the equivalent well that was the most
horror movie of all these because that
was like this music is like sort of
atonal yeah sounds like it's on our own
like frogs no good can come of this
what do you think what would be the
point of what ghosts doing that why
would it go start playing music I would
only do it to mess with someone I think
I would if I were a ghost I think it's
hilarious damn I would be using that
should be your goal like how how
sleepless can I make this person oh my
guys I'm right there with you and I
would totally pull so many pranks on a
life
people specifically my enemies when I
was alive I wouldn't kill them I would
hunt fellow ghosts like if I could scare
you then it's even better
I would only haunt people who are
praying to God to say they stopped
pretty I've brought you aside don't do
it I'm gonna play music too as he ghost
I will play something a little more fun
yeah like barbie girl by aqua or weird
al' yankovic music or the dark night
theme song can you have your blog sexy
in the city my blog is what I'm gonna do
after I die
okay I mean Iong in the city yeah you
got to be a ghost what would you would
you play over a baby monitor that exact
music that's creepy or or I'd have like
kids singing like I'm like creepy 9
we're like an acapella version of the
friends theme yeah like I would just
recite the like outdated Powerball
numbers the last one I think that was a
dead baby that looked like it could look
like an ad that could have been a ghost
baby that they had a horrible way to be
a ghost
baby what do you do what do you do
you're not developed enough to be dead
you know and you're not developed enough
to like make decisions in the afterlife
you know even to be stuck in the leg
business it's like what can you your
brains not even why would it be bees
left in purgatory how unfair this maybe
had a lot riding I'm wondering now if
you died as a baby you like stay a baby
and then you just don't you only have
the mind of a baby as a ghost well look
I do that Renee it's a question only oh
my god
I'll pray to him tonight because he
always answers back to be here right boy
only God forgives and sometimes babies
die on his lunch break so well this has
become weirdly a religious video and we
know religious videos always go over
well in common box
people hell yeah hell yeah hell yes
purgatory yeah subscribe to the real
rejects people subscribe top 5 unknowns
while you're at it click that
notification bell on every channel
content John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram he sometimes uses it
patreon.com slash surreal rejects become
a patron i ejected a self-promotion
Renea Ariel be mindful of how I say her
name Twitter and Instagram her social
media I think is blowing up and she is
also part of clever TV and clever news
go follow those guys that's where I get
all my celebrity news from I love
celebrity gossip did you hear about AJ
in 20 years ago do you go Robert Blake
leaving his gun at that restaurant Brad
Pitt and Angela
all right yeah I hate his marriage and
Jennifer Aniston Oh so afterbuzz TV and
she has her dating blog sexting in the
city it's not only about sex people it's
really about dating and Renee's crazy
dating adventures and liking people
adventures and falling in love
adventures so many adventures pretty
much just everything about Renee do you
want to know it's all in this blog so go
check it out take care